[Música]
y como ya adelantábamos a nuestros
titulares vamos a hablar sobre el
novelista tan sano abdul razak journal
quien fue galardonado con el premio
nobel de literatura de este año sub 21
además vamos a analizar las
implicaciones de este premio en la
literatura y en nuestra región abdul
razak nació en la isla de sants y arc en
1948 pero en los años 60 salió como
refugiado hacia reino unido donde es
profesor de la universidad de que suele
escribir en inglés sin embargo sus
relatos tienden a hablar sobre su natal
de assange y bar destacando en sus
textos el colonialismo que afecta a toda
áfrica para ello quiero darle la
bienvenida a nuestro primer invitado él
es juan álvarez escritor investigador en
el instituto caro y también cuerpo ha
publicado novelas como candidatos
muertos la ruidosa marcha de los mundos
y también aún en el agua -juan gracias
por estar aquí con nosotros en directo
américa buen día raúl buen día gracias
por limitación vamos a hablar por
supuesto de este premio nobel de
literatura-
2021 fue reconocido
el escritor es tan sano por relatar la
historia sobre el refugio él como
refugiado como hasta proceso de un
escritor al plasmar parte de su vida
invoca pues sus recuerdos dolorosos sus
recuerdos pues que tuvo que vivir
saliendo de áfrica para ir a reino unido
como influye esto un escritor en una
novela
bueno yo no he leído nada como
probablemente no lo he hecho casi nadie
pero si en general la literatura es una
construcción de la que echas mano de tu
experiencia pero también de las
experiencias de grupos sociales
alrededor tuyo no yo no tengo claro cuál
sea la historia de refugiado de urnas
al final de cuentas terminó estudiando
en inglaterra y formándose allí los
doctores profesores en inglaterra pero
sí ciertamente en la literatura siempre
ocurre que esa cuota de experiencia
vital acaba siendo definitiva no ahora
juan también pedían más inclusión más
diversidad en estos premios nobel de
literatura finalmente escogieron a este
escritor tan sano como lo hicieron
también hay críticos que dicen que
puedes buscando la diversidad se puede
mermar un poco la calidad o por buscar
diversidad puedes una persona que
no está en la capacidad de hacer esto
que es tan cierto hay detrás de todas
estas polémicas sobre la diversidad en
estos premios si no yo no creo que haya
nada de contradicción en eso creo que es
un premio hecho desde una academia
europea desde todas las comodidades
digamos
decimonónicas es un premio final de
cuentas pensado desde el siglo 19 y
llevaba una década entera premiando
escritores anglosajones europeos creo
que sí era definitivo y la academia lo
sabía
lo que pasa es que estas cuotas de
diversidad pues yo creo que para empezar
son insuficientes en cierto sentido pero
bueno también es porque esperamos
demasiado de un solo premio hubo una
polémica muy grande en 2018 cuando a
raíz como de denuncias de acoso sexual
de miembros de ese comité no se dio el
premio y un poco se esperaba que esto
ocurriera creo que el nombre en
particular que escogieron no es el
nombre que se esperaba no estaba como en
las quinielas de nadie pero ciertamente
me parece que son de esas presiones
internacionales que son sanas no digamos
no puedes pasar una década dos décadas
premiando solamente escritores europeos
y considerar que estás haciendo un
premio global eso le quería preguntar
juan cómo se escoge entonces a un novel
de literatura y qué implicaciones tiene
a usted como por ejemplo escritor de
ganar un premio tan prestigioso como
éste si no bueno creo que nadie tiene
muy claro idea de cómo funciona eso
porque además la academia se precia de
ser como este lugar muy hermética
hermético luego cerrado yo supongo que
cualquiera que conozca un poco el mundo
literario sabe que se mueve con la gente
es una pelea de nominaciones de cartas
ahí está por ejemplo el caso de gabriela
mistral que fue la primera premio nobel
latinoamericana un lobby como
internacional muy grande son premios que
no que no pasan únicamente por la obra
porque no pueden serlo digamos hay unas
presiones de agentes muy grandes para
sus premios políticos pues son premios
en donde
la experiencia o la expresión estética
está mezclada con la realidad como todo
como comando leemos por ejemplo son
premios que sólo son posibles por un
entramado de traducciones gigantescas no
puede que este premio por ejemplo en
particular sea de un autor que escribe
en inglés lo cual es un poco extraño
considerando como su enunciación
anticolonialista pero son premios sobre
todo que requieren de unos entramados de
traducción gigantescos no podríamos
conocer las obras de todos estos autores
que estuvieron nominados como no
europeos si no fuera por la red de
traducciones que se van construyendo
entonces son premios políticos por
supuesto en el sentido de que pues
tienen un impacto global muy grande como
cómo están los escritores latinos en el
día de hoy juan a su parecer no lo tengo
muy claro yo creo que no había muchas
posibilidades
creo que estaba como muy resuelto esta
idea de premiar un autor no occidental
insisto es extraño este señor yo no lo
conozco apenas estoy informando me pero
es una persona que sale de áfrica a los
20 años a estudio y se forma dentro del
dentro de dentro del entramado en inglés
con lo cual en algunos sentidos es
occidental pero yo creo que los
latinoamericanos estamos muy leídos y
muy identificados como autores que hacen
parte de la tradición occidental a
diferencia digamos de los chinos de los
japoneses de los asiáticos y de los
africanos entonces creo que los
latinoamericanos en esa lógica de que
venía un nobel no occidental pues
estaban como distantes nos falta más en
nuestra región a los escritores
latinoamericanos para estar más cercanos
a aspirar un premio como este puede ser
no lo sé
son muchas cosas que se desenvuelven ahí
son muchos poderes insisto de las
agencias literarias yo creo que obras
sin lugar a dudas ha habido una obra
monumental hace dos dos o tres años
murió uno de mis poetas favoritos de
canal para raquel siempre siempre cuando
me interesó el nobel siempre soñé que él
se lo ganará pero sí supongo que más que
faltar nos en términos de expresión
estética que sin duda alguna no nos
falta porque la escritura
latinoamericana el relato
latinoamericano es una cosa monumental
sobre todo en los últimos 20 o 30 años
cuando yo creo que se han desatado
muchas cosas pero si hay unos poderes de
agencias literarias que yo creo que sí
son como incomprensibles o sea a mí me
desborda le quiero preguntar si los
problemas sociales en nuestra región
también son un poco de impedimento para
que se desarrollan más literarios para
que sea root para que se desarrolle más
la cultura del arte en nuestra región
bueno sí sin duda la inequidad siempre
será un factor
que desigual hará la capacidad de
expresión estética
en este momento en américa latina por
ejemplo yo creo que sería definitivo la
posibilidad de que las comunidades
indígenas
empezaran a tener mucha más visibilidad
lo que escriben porque hay poetas y hay
autores indígenas en toda américa latina
pero eso requiere como de unas
estructuras de traducción requiere como
de unas posibilidades culturales mucho
más sólidas que por lo general no se
traducen en las inversiones de las
naciones no estos países están siempre
afiliados por la inequidad la guerra
contra las drogas la protesta hay
demasiada tensión como para que hayan
inversiones culturales e importantes
como trabajo usted desde la escritura
creativa del instituto caro y cuervo
para poder poder desarrollar todo esto
que estamos hablando y no sé si también
le pregunto trabajo con jóvenes para
pues ayudarlos a desarrollar su
creatividad sí claro en el instituto
justamente llevamos unos ocho años
construyendo un proyecto de escritura
creativa que nos gusta pensar que es más
allá de la literatura y va más hacia el
relato que es un asunto digamos mucho
más
social y comunitario parte de lo que
hemos trabajado en nuestra línea de
investigación es últimos dos o tres años
es escritura con comunidades hemos
sacado publicaciones con firmantes de
paz con comunidades negras con
activistas trans y yo creo que lo que
pasa es que esa palabra escrita no suele
ser apropiada por grupos sociales que a
veces tienen otras afugias o no les
parece tan relevante y creo que nosotros
lo que hemos ido construyendo ahí es una
especie de transición para poder
construir ese relato con comunidades
pues juegan gracias por su tiempo y por
estar aquí en directo américa en francés
y 4 en tener un poco pues este premio
nobel como se escoge y también como
estamos en américa latina en la
literatura juan gracias no ustedes raúl
muchas gracias